la pression de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé de l'église catholique
tanzaniennes et de certains journalistes
et médecins anonyme semble avoir porté
ses fruits jamais je n'ai dit que vous
ne devriez pas porter de masque ne me
citez pas en disant cela
si vous devez porter un masque utiliser
ceux fabriqués par notre ministère de la
santé si vous n'en avez pas les moyens
fabriquer votre propre masque je vous
dis ça parce que je suis avec vous je
sais que nous sommes en guerre c'est un
véritable conflit
samedi dernier lot à metz avait alerté
sur la situation dans le pays et avait
incité le gouvernement tanzanien a
appliqué des mesures fortes
des décisions qui semblent comprise et
bien accepté par la population
[Musique]
il y à des groupes de personnes dans
notre communauté qui l'ignorent mais la
plupart des gens qui comprennent les
conséquences du coc vite 19 portent des
masques
les déclarations du président sont donc
les bienvenus mais devant la hausse des
décès liés à de soi-disant pneumonie
aiguë et des hôpitaux bondés de patients
sous oxygène ces nouvelles mesures
arrivent peut-être un peu trop tard les
gens portent des masques
récemment mais pas en grand nombre par
rapport à la première vague presque tout
le monde portaient des masques mais pas
autant dans cette deuxième vague de
covit 19 certaines personnes leur font
de leur propre initiative sans y être
forcé pour des raisons politiques et
idéologiques et contrairement à d'autres
pays d'afrique comme la côte d'ivoire le
gouvernement refuse d'adhérer au kovacs
ce dispositif qui permet aux pays les
plus pauvres de bénéficier de vaccins
financé aux trois quarts par l'europe et
les états unis avec seulement 509 cas et
21 décès recensés la tanzanie est
suspecté de ne pas avoir mis les
chiffres à jour depuis avril 2020